[MUSIC PLAYING]
NISHA SHARMA: And for
the past several years,
I've been working on
our mobility solutions,
building all sorts of
applications, strategies,
helping our clients
build applications
for themselves and their
workers and employees.
And today, I am here with
my colleague Phil Redman.
He'll be joining us
on stage shortly.
And we're going to be talking
about the next generation
of mobile applications,
particularly powered
by Android and Google Cloud.
So with that, just
to kind of describe
a little bit about what we're
seeing, where we are, apps,
as we look at them--
I mean, they're not new.
We've been doing mobile
apps for a long time,
probably since the
late '90s really is
when we've been
building different types
of mobile applications.
But over the years, we've seen
that the types of applications
we build and the interactions
and the integrations
that we have, all of these
things, are changing.
And with the next
generation of apps,
we're starting to see
new technologies that
are being introduced
that allow us
to do even more powerful things
with Enterprise Mobility.
So we're seeing a focus more
on end-to-end solutions.
It's not just about the front
end or the back end or any one
component.
But we have to look at it
from all of those things,
plus cloud, plus security.
We really have to look at
these as end-to-end solutions.
We're seeing that a
lot of new innovation
is being driven because of
the advances in technology.
So for the past several
years, I would say,
you know, honestly,
we haven't really
been innovating in the
space of mobile apps.
We had been taking things
from desktop and paper
and then putting them
on mobile devices.
But we hadn't really
been doing new things
with those mobile applications.
And so we'll talk a
lot more about that.
And then in order
to support that,
there are a lot of
things that need
to happen on the back
end side to support
those new applications.
And in many, many cases, we
don't have access to data today
that we need to have access to.
Or perhaps the back
end systems just
aren't able to support
what we need to do.
And so we have a number of new
types of back end architectures
and platform capabilities
that really enable
us to do things in that space.
So here's the agenda real quick.
We're going to talk about the
evolution of mobile apps, where
we were, where we're going,
look into the next generation
of mobile apps, and then
talk about how we're really
transforming those
apps in the enterprise,
and then some of our
recommendations for how
to build next
generation applications.
So if we look at
the overall timeline
of mobile applications, like I
said, this chart goes to 2005.
But in reality,
like I said, we've
been doing this
since the late '90s.
I mean, you might remember--
maybe some of you
might remember--
BlackBerrys and Windows mobile
devices and Windows CE devices
and those types of applications.
And so we look at
that time as what we
call Enterprise Mobility 1.0.
And it was all
about more just, how
do I get email on my devices?
How do I get calendar?
How do I do text messaging?
Very simple types
of applications
that we were doing.
And then we started
to shift more
towards Enterprise
Mobility 2.0, which
is where we really
started to take
a more mobile first approach.
So like I said, it wasn't about
taking desktop applications
and putting them on mobile.
But now we're really
looking at, what
are those use cases that
really apply to mobile devices
to allow us to take
advantage of what's happening
on those mobile devices?
And then we started to move
towards Enterprise Mobility
3.0, which is
where we are today.
But we're shifting into
Enterprise Mobility
4.0 as well, or the
next generation really.
And Enterprise Mobility 3.0
is more about transforming
how we're doing work today.
It's about introducing
new types of technologies
that, like I said, it's
not about now going
from paper to the
phone, but it's
about how do we
really change the way
our workers do their jobs.
And so we'll show
you some examples
of how we're doing that.
Oh, sorry, but I'll
also say is you
can see here that the
types of applications
that we were building have
evolved over time as well.
So we've had mobile websites,
native apps, web apps,
hybrid apps.
All of this has changed.
We still continue to use
these types of applications.
But we continue to see newer
and newer types of applications
evolve.
And then the way we
interact with the data,
with our devices,
that's also changing.
So it used to be way
back when we had a stylus
and we had to tap on
our device and our app.
Then we started to be
able to use our finger.
Then we introduced gestures, so
the device could see your eyes
moving on the screen.
And then taking
advantage of some
of the context
aware capabilities,
so that the device
knew where we were.
It knew a little bit
more about the situation,
the present situation, and
perhaps even the past situation
to provide new ways
to interact with us.
We're doing a lot
more with voice now.
So with the emergence of
voice assistance and voice
capabilities, we're seeing a
lot of voice to text and text
to voice to allow us to interact
a little bit differently.
And then, of course,
artificial intelligence,
which we'll talk about a
little bit here as well.
So while there's all
these advancements
in these technologies,
enterprises are actually
quite slow to adopt these.
And if you think
about ourselves,
in our own everyday
use of our own devices,
the average consumer has
about 30 applications
on their phones.
But if you look at
the enterprise side,
the average is about eight.
But it's growing,
and it's changing.
And we're going to take a look
at some of the challenges that
are behind that.
But the types of applications
that enterprises do
use and do buy, we consider
off-the-shelf or packaged
applications or
packaged applications
that might require some
level of customization
or some level of personalization
to be able to use them.
And then on the other side, we
have total custom applications.
So these are apps that have
been built from scratch.
And so you've designed
the whole experience.
You've built everything,
perhaps using
design-led thinking
or new approaches
to designing applications.
But they are very custom.
But when you put that together,
you can see that about 70%
of the applications
that we're building
have some sort of
development required
in order to actually use them.
But going to some
of the challenges
of why it's difficult, we will
talk about some of these here.
So if you look at the
platform challenges,
even if you just look
at Android itself,
as I'm sure you
all know, Android
has got many different versions.
And different features
work on different versions.
And so we have to
account for those.
And then you start to
introduce other platforms.
Maybe you're also supporting iOS
or maybe you've got mobile web.
And then you really
need to start
to understand, what
can I do on each
of those different platforms?
How do I manage that?
And how do I account for that?
Ultimately, then means that you
have higher development costs
and operating costs,
because as you
may know, for each of the
different types of applications
you have to build, that just
requires more development
work to make it happen.
Enterprises usually have
limited resources and knowledge.
They don't necessarily have
the expertise in security.
Or perhaps they don't
have the right designers.
have the experts
in the back end
integration or security
or even the right
front end developers
to be able to build some
of the applications.
And sometimes business
cases are hard to prove out
for many companies.
And they can't always
demonstrate the value
that they're getting from
the mobile applications.
And then when you compare
that to the cost, sometimes
the cost just outweighs
the perceived value.
And the last one there, the
constant kind of tension
between business and IT.
Oftentimes businesses look
to IT and the IT groups
can't support them as quickly
as the businesses might want.
Or perhaps the IT groups are
looking at the businesses
and saying, what you're trying
to do is really not reasonable,
or it's just not
possible, or maybe it's
going to take a
little bit of time
because we have to put some
things in place in order
to support that.
So there is this
kind of challenge.
But let's talk about the next
generation of applications.
And as I mentioned, this journey
from Moblilty 1.0 to 3.0--
and I think Google Maps
is a great example of that
and something we can
all relate to right.
So if we think back to the
early days of Google Maps,
really all you could
do was get directions.
You had to put in
an address, and it
would give you directions.
And at one point,
you actually had
to print out a list
of the directions,
because it wasn't actually
navigating you there.
So then in Mobility
2.0, we started
to see things like navigation
and traffic introduced.
And we could plug
in multiple points.
So it could actually suggest
the right routes and ways
to go right and
things like that.
So we started to get a
little bit more advanced.
And with Mobility
3.0, now we're really
using maps in a
very different way.
It's not just about getting
directions or figuring out
how to get somewhere.
But it's about exploring places.
Now when you look up something,
you go to Maps and you search,
you have reviews.
You've got other
location information.
Perhaps you've got
hours of business.
There's just a lot
more information there.
You're able to share.
Now Maps is integrated
with more things.
So even Google Assistant
is integrated with Maps.
So it knows what
your habits are.
It knows which location
is home or work.
And it can suggest,
hey, you have
an appointment at this time.
You should leave at this time
in order to get there in time.
So it's just really changed
the way we're using Maps.
It's not just about
directions anymore.
So hopefully you can see how
over time, the applications
and technology have
allowed us to build
more exciting applications.
So on the consumer side--
that's a consumer application--
but the enterprise expectations
are continuing to
increase because
of these really cool
consumer applications that
are out there.
So some of these, for example,
mobile business models,
I mean the Uber models or
the micro-payments or mobile
advertising, these
are all capabilities
that businesses can take
advantage of and include
in their enterprise
solutions as well.
We expect these really
personalized experience.
Just like how we get
in the consumer apps,
we want those things for
our work applications too.
We want to be able to use social
media types of applications
and be able to share and
collaborate with other people
that we work with.
Contextual awareness--
our application
should know that perhaps I
did a particular function
on my desktop and
now I'm picking it up
on my phone or my tablet
or on a different device,
and taking all that
information into account.
The payment capabilities-- and
then the natural and intuitive
interfaces, this is something
I think enterprises typically
didn't really focus
on this in the past.
It was really just, you know,
hey, it's for our employees.
They just need
something that works.
And they don't really focus
on that user experience.
And then they found that
their employees weren't
happy with the applications.
They were complaining about it.
I was recently at a
pretty major store,
and they had rolled out
a new mobile application
to all the cashiers
and store workers.
And all the people,
like all their employees
were complaining about this
app to me as a customer.
They're like, I
can't use this app.
It's terrible.
We can't do like what we
used to do on the other one.
Or you know, I can't
figure out like--
and they were just complaining.
And that just really
shows the importance
of having these really
good interfaces and designs
with our enterprise
applications as well.
So the nice thing is that
we've got these really great
technologies now that are
allowing us to provide
these better experiences.
So voice assistance, we've
got Google Assistant.
We've got Google Home.
We've got Dialogflow
to allow us to create
conversations and provide
a more conversational type
of experience.
Immersive applications
are augmented
reality and virtual reality.
So we're able to use ARCore and
Daydream and the SDKs and all
that they provide, so
that we can, again,
provide these really exciting
experiences through AR and BR.
IoT applications,
of course, being
able to use sensors all around
us that we can communicate
with and provide
additional information
or additional capabilities
that we didn't have before.
We mentioned the
context of where
machine learning
and AI-- and I think
this is one of the
most exciting places.
And [? Faitbeh ?] was
talking about that as well.
But we're now building
in capabilities
such as natural language
processing, image recognition,
prediction, all of
these capabilities
to allow us to make
our apps smarter.
And then Instant Apps, which
Phil will show is a demo about,
but it's really being
able to take action
at that point of desire, rather
than having to go and download
applications and find out
where in the application
you need to go.
But these are just
instant functions
that we can do right away.
So a lot of advancements
on the device itself.
If you think about the
smartphones that you all have,
just look year after
year at all the changes
that you see in terms of device
processing time, where now
we've got multicore processors
that can be 2 and 1/2 times
faster than single
core processors.
That allows us to
do the AR and the VR
and the machine learning
on the devices, especially
the Edge analytics type of
work that we can do as well.
The screens and the
cameras, every year
there's this kind of
competition to see
who has the better camera.
And it's always about us
taking selfies and pictures.
But the cameras and
the screen resolution
really allow us to get much
more accurate and precise
with things like image
recognition or AR/VR.
And so it allows us to do a
lot more with that information.
The sensors, we talked about
as well-- fingerprint sensors,
accelerometers, ambient
light sensors, and so on.
And then wearables
as well, we have
a wide variety of
whether it's watches
or glasses or any other
number of wearable devices
that allow us to have a
much better experience.
And so as you look
at all of these,
the nice thing with
Android is that you
have a variety of devices and
form factors and price points.
So enterprises can
pick the right device
that meets their
needs and matches
what they're trying to do.
So some examples of some of the
technologies that are providing
these experiences.
We've already talked
a bit about context
aware and how our applications
can adapt to our environment
or to our situation or
to whatever it might be.
The AI powered applications,
again our applications
are getting smarter.
They're learning more
about all sorts of things.
They're taking advantage
of a lot of data
that we hadn't had
before, getting
into recommendations, into
personalization, and so on.
Self-learning
applications-- so this
is about the app
learning itself and how
it can take different actions
based on what it's experiencing
and what it's been
learning over time.
And Edge analytics,
this is the ability to--
you may be familiar with
the TensorFlow and Cloud
ML and these kinds of image
recognition capabilities
that we've been doing
for a few years.
But that's in the cloud.
And now we can actually
do these things
with TensorFlow Lite and
some of the neural networks
API and things like that.
We can do it right
on the device.
We don't even need
to go to the cloud.
And so that allows us to
do things in more real time
and just get a much better
experience in that way, which
is really exciting.
IoT-based applications,
we're seeing
lots of examples of those.
You can see those
in health care.
You can see those in retail.
You can see those
in manufacturing
and so on, where
we're really trying
to take advantage of the
sensors and the other machines
that are around us to try to
provide a better experience.
Immersive applications,
voice assisted, templatize--
templatize applications,
we list this here,
but I haven't really seen a
lot of success with those.
That's really where
third-party providers
might provide a template
type of an application, which
you would build off of
and perhaps customize
a lot more than normal.
But many have tried
it, but it's just not
as successful from some of
what I've personally seen.
So now, I'm going to
transition it over to Phil.
And Phil will come and
first do our first demo
with our voice-based
digital system.
Phil.
PHILLIP REDMAN: Great.
Great.
Can you hear me OK?
Thank you, Nisha.
I'm Phil Redman.
I'm in a part of our
digital transformation team.
So I work with clients
globally to help them
around mobility, security, big
data and analytics, AI machine
learning, and of course
mobile technologies.
And so we're
working with clients
to help transform
what they're doing.
And here's an example
of one that I'll
show you is about an
organization called
West Midlands Police.
They're the second largest
police force in the UK,
so over 10,000
police officers, just
a bit smaller than the London
police force, the London Metro.
And they're really
looking at how
to modernize the police
force going forward and using
mobile devices, specifically
Android mobile devices.
And so we worked with them
to get an understanding
of how we can accommodate
police officers as they're
going towards
different incidences
and how to support them when
they get to those instances.
So we're going to show
you an example of what
that looks like.
And we've created
what we call part
of a digital virtual
mobile system.
Now you might be familiar
with virtual assistants.
And there's lots
of varieties here.
But it's an idea of more of
a voice-based interaction
for the police officers.
Obviously, in many cases, police
officers will be in their cars.
They may be by themselves.
They may not have hands to be
able to navigate information.
At the same time, they want
to find out information
when they're on the move.
They don't have a
lot of time once they
get to what they call
an incident to find out
that information.
So we worked together
with them in order
to understand how they can
better be better supported
by having information
at their hands
and understanding what's going
on as they arrive, and then
improves on the process that
they have once they arrive too,
all by using a digital
virtual assistant.
So just like we may use a
digital virtual assistant,
like Google Assistant
or Siri in order
to help us with our task--
we're taking messages
or making phone calls
or doing searches--
they're looking to
see how they can
use voice-based digital
systems also in their work.
So I'm going to switch
over to the Chromecast now.
Can we put it up on the screen?
Can you see the Chromecast?
Is it casting?
I'll try and make sure--
must have canceled out there.
There we go.
So as you can see when
we worked with them,
we didn't want to give them
a typical kind of Android
app that may be part of the
material design features
that they might be used to.
We wanted to give them something
that was very type of voice
oriented.
So you can see there's
no soft keys that we
have here for navigation.
They can completely
navigate by voice.
Now, we did give
them an opportunity
by using the sliding menu
to be also navigating.
But we didn't give them any
buttons on the side here
in order to navigate.
And so they're easily
able to hear information.
As you can see here,
this is an incident
that they might be seeing.
These are, of course,
made up incidences.
But these are incidences
that they might be seeing.
And so simply by
pushing on them,
they can hear the information.
Now when they get a report, they
may not just get one report,
they may get additional
information as they're going.
So you can see here there's all
different types of information
that may be coming along.
By simply just pushing on this--
I don't think you can hear it.
I click on the Do Not Disturb.
That might be the reason why.
Can you hear it?
VIRTUAL ASSISTANT:
Gather witness statement.
Location HA 0 1 at
Wembley London minus.
Case number minus 128,781.
Scout area for CCTV footage.
Location SW 13-9 by
Hounslow London minus.
PHILLIP REDMAN: So you can see
how the digital information
keeps coming out, they
can hear all the updates.
So that's one thing
that they could do.
They could also navigate
the application.
So if they wanted to
make a phone call,
just like with a
regular assistant,
they can push our
little button here.
Go to blue k pages.
VIRTUAL ASSISTANT:
Sorry, I didn't get that.
PHILLIP REDMAN:
Go to blue pages.
VIRTUAL ASSISTANT: OK,
showing the blue pages.
PHILLIP REDMAN: So they can
either go to their directory
that they have here.
Or they can call
up someone's name
and they can say,
call or message, etc.
The other thing we
wanted to do was
give them advanced capability
for taking witness statements.
So today, they take all
their witness statements
in the analog way, with
basically a pencil and paper.
And so those may
not be accurate.
Now, we can start a new
witness statement here.
Start a new witness statement.
VIRTUAL ASSISTANT: OK, here's
a new witness statement.
PHILLIP REDMAN: And by
simply pushing the icon,
they can start retrieving
information from the witness.
And it takes the
notes right for them
in the statement,
which they can go and--
oh, we shot off.
There we go.
Maybe a little nosy in here--
they can take the notes right
on the witness statement
and then go and edit them later.
So you can see this comes up.
We can also integrate this
into Google Translate.
And so if there's
another language
that someone's speaking,
they can then translate that
onto English right there.
Now today, they still need to
actually print out the witness
statements and get them signed.
So they can't use
this for court.
But it gives them an accurate
way of collecting the data.
Much more accurate than it
was with pencil and paper.
So some pretty cool stuff using
a digital virtual assistant
for the police force.
All right, can we switch back
to the presentation now, please?
So as you know, there
are some standard ways
that we've been
developing mobile apps
for many, many years.
And we get asked this
quite a bit, what's
the best way--
from our clients--
what's the best way that we
should develop our mobile apps?
What technology, what
platform should we be using?
And a lot of it goes into,
who's the app being used for?
Is it for the customer?
Is it for their employees?
Is it with a partner?
What platforms are they using?
Are they single or are
there multiple platforms?
In many cases, the
majority of applications,
especially for customers,
we develop still
in the native format.
And so most applications
today are still
using the native capabilities,
whether the Android SDK
or for Apple.
It gives them the
richest type of interface
that they can have,
high levels of security.
It's something that everybody
wants to do today typically
for their customers.
And when you have a
large number of users
that will be using that app,
it makes a lot of sense.
But for internal users, it
may not make as much sense,
because you have a
smaller internal employee
force to develop that app.
And there actually
may be, and what we
see in most cases, multiple
platforms that are supported
within the enterprise space.
So they may support both
Android and Apple capabilities.
And so they're
looking at building
more of a hybrid
app that has kind
of the best of both
worlds for native and web,
a single development platform
to support the applications
that they have.
Obviously, there,
as an advantage
is the operating pieces on that.
The testing, the development,
and then the operating costs
are much lower
because you don't have
to support individual
applications
and individual platforms.
And so we're seeing an increased
demand from our customer base
to support more of
these hybrid apps.
And that's across a number of
different hybrid development
technologies.
Mobile web is an early
way for developing
apps, web-based apps.
But they haven't
been very responsive.
And so obviously you
need a good connection.
You don't have an
offline capability.
They are OS agnostic.
But the interface and
the usability of those
typically are a lot lower.
And so we don't really build
a lot of mobile web apps.
They're just not
really demanded.
But we think that there
are opportunities for this
to change in the future with
kind of more of the next
generation of mobile apps
that we're going to focus
on, including-- how do I
get this thing to work--
progressive web apps, micro
apps, and instant apps.
Does anyone here have any
experience with progressive web
apps at all?
Raise your hand.
Just one person.
So been around for a little bit,
introduced not too long ago,
but been around for a bit, where
you could take the benefits
of native and increased
capability for mobile web
apps-- so these are web apps--
they're instantly shareable.
There linkable.
You can send someone a link.
You don't need to download
these from an app store.
And they have a
functionality that's
improved performance
overall for mobile users.
And so we see certainly
and playing around
with some of these
different capabilities,
only supported on Android
today, not supported on iOS.
But we think that these could
be some interesting ways
of improving some of that
experience for mobile web apps.
And it gives a much lower
cost for development and lower
operating costs overall.
Micro apps are another way that
we think that are expanding.
So micro apps are
highly targeted apps,
very application specific
apps, very simple to use.
They may live and sit
right on the desktop.
They have a very limited
amount of functionality.
An example of a micro app may
be something like weather,
for instance.
Or you could see in the future
where maybe Uber would put out
a micro app, where all you
do is just push the button
and in five minutes
your car shows up.
So think about that, like if
you're familiar with the Amazon
buttons where you just push it
and your case of water shows up
a day or two later.
The same thing for mobility,
just push the button
and you get the information.
So very, very low cost to
develop, very low cost to use.
I mean, even today, we've
seen that apps and native apps
have grown in complexity,
where they have so many windows
and screens and clicks in
order to get the information.
And mobility is all
about the here and now.
Its about how to do that
much quicker and easier.
And you can't get
quicker and easier
than a micro app, which
can deliver the information
or the service ASAP.
And then finally, we're going to
show you and talk a little bit
about these Instant Apps.
Is anyone familiar
with Instant Apps
introduced a few years ago?
Not too many people here.
So an Instant App
are app functions
that launch without
downloading an app.
So it's a web-based app.
Now built in native
capabilities,
but they can leverage
those native capabilities
that make it much easier to
develop and much quicker.
And I'll show you some examples
of what we mean by that.
They are fairly limited.
But they're very, very
easy to use and deploy.
So they're great if
you're only using
the app on a one-time basis
or for a short-term, temporary
basis.
So today even for things
like these conferences,
we may download the conference
app and we use it for the week,
but do we really need to
have it sit on our device?
How many people here
have downloaded apps
that they've used only
temporarily or for one-time use
and then deleted it
off their device?
With Instant Apps, you won't
have to do that anymore.
Again, only available
for Android platforms.
So I'm going to show you
kind of what that means.
If we go back to the
Chromecast, this is a native app
that we developed for a client
for a package delivery service
last year.
This is a full native app
that lives on the device.
In a package
delivery service, you
have people that are
scanning packages in,
putting them on
trucks, and then you
have people that are
delivering the packages.
Now sometimes that's
the same person,
but often times it's
a different person.
So the driver who's driving
and delivering those packages
would get this app, but they
might not do any scanning.
So when you log into this
app, you can see here there's
an ability that they
could just click on here
and they can scan packages in.
So if we have my little
bar code reader here,
it reads the bar code.
It scans the package.
You get the information in.
But this is a full
native app, including
turn by turn directions
and instructions
that we have built on
Google and Android platform,
complete with Google
Firebase on the back end.
On the front end, we
have Google Maps in here.
We have image recognition,
all different types
of capabilities for this.
But for a person
just scanning it,
do they really need to have
this full type of application?
So I have another device here.
I'm going to bring this one up.
And this is going to
show you an Instant App
that we developed that kind
of does the same thing.
And so let's say the package
scanner comes into work,
we can send them an email.
So just through this
email right here,
you can see they get a link.
No downloading anything from app
store, no pushing anything out,
simply click on the link, and an
Instant App will open right up.
They could just log in with
their credentials and then,
boom, start scanning in
seconds, the same type of idea.
Very, very low cost to
develop, very easy to do.
And then, boom,
when they're done,
they just click out of the
app and then they're done.
They can save the link for
the future, whatever that is.
And so we can send them
a link every morning.
They can put it
in their calendar.
So very easy to use.
So you can imagine a plethora
of different ideas of how
you could use these
Android Instant
Apps for both
potential temporary use
or for short-term use
or for people that don't
need a full app capabilities.
So not a lot of this being
used in the marketplace yet,
but we see a whole
lot of interest.
And we think there are a
whole lot of capabilities
to come out with this.
All right, we can go back to
the presentation now, please.
So those are two examples
of us working with clients
and developing and using
some of these new generation
technologies.
The first one using capabilities
like machine learning and AI.
So with the natural
voice recognition,
you can see how
easily that works,
even within the
conference hall here
when it's noisy, and
natural language speech,
all those types of
things that we can use
using the Google technologies.
So capabilities, they're
simplifying in many ways.
But they're offering
more capabilities.
So with these micro
apps, some examples here,
simply maybe ordering
something off a menu,
approving a vacation
request, approving
T&E. Different microflow, so
integration now into enterprise
application platforms like
Salesforce.com or Workday
and ServiceNow, so
capabilities of supporting that
not just a web-based
capability, but integrated
into really robust information.
And then microservices--
so as we all know,
microservices are
growing in demand
to incorporate more
support and capabilities
across these different
types of devices.
So what does this take
in order to support
a lot of these next
gen app capabilities?
You've heard about some
stuff on the front end.
So we have hardware,
software, network capabilities
that have evolved to support
a much richer capability
for these mobile apps.
So the bottom line is
we feel with our clients
there's no excuses anymore.
There's nothing holding us back.
Even costs have come
down-- costs of hardware,
for services, for
cloud capabilities.
There's really very few barriers
to do almost anything out there
today, except for there
is an issue of back end.
What we run into all the
time is back end complexity.
So depending on
the industry, they
could be a regulated industry.
They could be an industry that's
been around for a long time.
They don't have APIs
that are developed,
and they don't have an
easy way of accessing
their corporate data.
If we could just erase
everything from our clients
and start over, the world
would be much simpler,
but it be a very, very
expensive place to go.
And so how do we access
that data for them
to put it onto these kind
of front end capabilities
that we're talking about?
So we're not only thinking about
that front end development,
but also the back end.
And there's lots of
cool stuff that's
happening on the back end
to make this all work.
So we're going from
monolithic structures, which
have been easy to deploy,
no scalability issues,
but difficult to add features,
to much more scalable,
with client server
capabilities, and now
into more micro services.
And so a micro service is a
platform and an architecture,
software architecture,
that can easily integrate
into business services.
And it can break down
the different application
needs into these
different services
that you can easily
build once and then
use across all different
types of mobile platforms.
So you can eliminate a
single point of failure,
because if one, let's say,
business service goes down,
there's still other services
that would be available.
There isn't one
level of integration.
They're very, very scalable.
And most importantly,
they're reusable.
So we could build
stuff for some clients.
And then we can reuse
those microservices
across different clients.
Very easy, very
fast, very, very low
cost to build these services.
They're very, very
rich too, so they
can support complex
orchestration
across different data stores,
across different platforms,
across different types
of mobile devices,
across different data types.
So very, very,
very complex stuff
that's built down and
integrated very easily.
And they use this business
logic layer as a service.
It's a new digital
orchestration layer
that we think that's
really important
that's evolved in part of the
mobile back end as a service
capability.
So going from monolithic to
more modular capabilities.
So we can take these different
services and drop them in place
and customize those for
different types of employees,
for different
types of customers,
for different types
of needs on the go,
again, using the front end
capabilities of Instant
Apps, progressive web
apps, micro apps, etc.
They flow across all those
different capabilities.
So we can customize whatever
those employee needs are,
whatever the mobile needs are,
to the back end capabilities,
instead of having to
build that out each time.
That's what we really
have to do today.
We typically have to build
something specialized
out each time.
And that's very, very
time consuming and very,
very expensive.
And so where we're going
from 12 to 24 months
to build these
things out, we can
do these in a matter
of days in many cases.
So very, very rich, and very,
very awesome capabilities.
It also doesn't exclude
any of the intelligence
that these next
generation apps need.
So whether the apps
need to be deployed
or they don't have
context, they can't
see the backend
capabilities or they're
very limited in
what they can see,
right now we can add in
that backend intelligence.
Same intelligence that we
see on more richer apps,
we could even do that
on these basic apps too.
We can support connected
capabilities on App Services.
So there's a common
framework that integrates
these disconnected back ends.
And we can support them
offline, real time configuration
of new events or engagements
or anything that comes out.
All doing that on
the flow, on the go.
And so as you may be
familiar with, a lot of this
is done through a mobile
as a backend system.
Is anyone here
familiar with MBES,
mobile as a backend system,
if you raise your hand.
Oh, OK, not too many people.
Surprisingly, these things have
been out for a long, long time,
over six, seven years.
And the idea was that this
mobile as a backend system
would be a platform
that does two things.
One would be a very quick
and easy development
that works across all different
types of mobile platforms.
So you can develop a
mobile front end, typically
in a hybrid app capability to
support any type of platform,
whether it's Android,
whether it was BlackBerry,
whether it was Apple.
So easy way to develop.
The second part of it was,
though, an easy integration.
So APIs built right
into the application,
a mobile backend piece that was
integrated into your business
services to be able
to support and get
the data from your back end
onto these mobile devices very
easy and very cheaply.
So like I said, this has
been around for a while.
As you can see, nobody
here has been using them.
And we don't see a
whole lot of use in this
yet, because there have
been some challenges
on the back end.
Basically the front end
hasn't been very rich.
There was still more
development that
needed to be done on
those front ends in order
to make them work.
And so again, most
people have been
kind of focusing on
consumer applications
and going straight in to
that kind of front end
development and native
application development.
So what we see here is with the
emergence of the microservices
we can add in a new layer to
increase the capabilities, what
we're calling this digital
orchestration layer,
to an existing mobile
backend service
to start supporting
those microservices
that I mentioned before.
So then a very, very quick
way and very low cost way,
whether it's a native
app, whether it's a web
app, a hybrid app, to support
the backend capability.
So it's going to bring in a
lot more intelligence and a lot
easier to develop and such.
And so obviously, this does
increase the number of APIs
that the organization
may need to build out
in order to support
those different services.
But we believe that this will
be a much faster and easier way
and maybe more successful way of
getting these applications out
into the hands,
getting the data out
into the hands of
the mobile workers.
As Nisha said, we have all these
technologies and capabilities
and the consumer world has
really grown dramatically,
but the enterprise
world has still
have been very limited in
support for a lot of the data.
And so for these next
generation app services
we want to look at, things
to think about in the future
are the support for
more liquid apps.
So liquid has
become a term that's
fairly popular out there.
But what we mean with this
is much more agile apps.
So apps that can be
changed on the fly, where
new data can be
brought in, where
they can be updated on the fly.
So we don't want to think of
these apps as just static.
And every time there's
an update, to the OS,
we need to change
some of those apps.
So what's a better
way of doing that
versus kind of
rewriting the whole app
or having to patch
those apps all the time?
So we have to think
of new ways to support
these kind of liquid apps.
Connected App Services are
another huge consideration
when it comes down to
the app capabilities.
So we want to look at
the different services,
so with the backend
capabilities,
whether they're intelligent
services, Salesforce.com
capabilities, or ERP, whatever
that might be out there.
So how can we support
these different services
and add context to that?
So it knows my location, just
like we showed on the map
with Enterprise 3.0,
it knows where we're
standing on the map, so
it can recommend coffee
for us or other things that
we might want during our day.
Can we do the same thing
for the enterprise?
So an example on that
is one of our clients
wanted to be able to build
in intelligence services
to their Salesforce.com
that showed them on the map
where their customers are and
then be able to kind of look
into those customer base and
see what are their recent sales
or even use machine learning
to make recommendations
of new opportunities to
sell within that customer.
So of course, most
salespeople have a schedule
and they have a
calendar that they're
following during the day.
But we also know that
meetings get canceled
or they may find some
more time during the day.
So what's the easiest
way to kind of find out
how to optimize that downtime?
So this whole idea of
assisted selling is huge.
Now by simply
looking onto the map,
by seeing where
the customers are,
finding customer
information, they're
able to then make
recommendations and then
potentially do
additional revenue
that they hadn't thought
of during the day before.
So lots of intelligent
app services that we see
are being built into these apps.
Now, of course, with those
capabilities, lots of API calls
are going to need to be made.
So they need to have
high performance app
services that can scale.
So we test out for
those apps all the time,
but that's going to be a huge
consideration, because there's
going to be more and
more data coming.
Whether it's from the cloud,
whether it's from on-premise
on the enterprise, wherever
that may be, lots of API
calls that are going to
be made during the day.
It needs to be digital ready.
And so that means how
can we use analytics
in order to improve whatever
the application may be?
How can we improve
the interface?
the mobile experience?
How can we make sure that
security, although is strong,
doesn't become a barrier to
use of these different apps?
And so digital ready is
a huge piece on that.
And then as I mentioned with
the new digital orchestration
services, how can
we make sure that we
have the right APIs
that are easily
built into those apps for
today and in the future
to improve those services and
add services on to make them
ready to go in the future?
So some key
recommendations and then we
can take some questions.
So we think around these
next generation apps,
they're not just aligning
to your digital strategy
and the transformation
at most organizations,
but they're going to
become a big part, if not
the part of their digital
transformation strategy.
A lot of the data and
the traffic as you see
has already moved
off of desktops
and moving onto mobile devices.
And so this has to
fully align and really
help drive a lot of the
transformation strategy.
Also put a strategy together
to help modernize your app
architectures.
And so the best thing
that we see on this
is that it's no longer siloed
between your mobile device,
between your portable
devices, and then, of course,
between your laptop or
your desktop devices
that may be being used.
A lot of these capabilities
can go across any
of those different platforms.
And so it's a write once work
anywhere type of scenario,
which builds a big
integrated approach
and helps reduce the
time for development
and reduce the
cost in the future.
And so when we're doing the
strategy for our clients,
we're not looking at mobility
as a standalone capability.
We're looking at as
part of the solution
on how to take data from
one area to the next,
from one device to
the next, and how
to think about the
data access and not
think about the
device or the network.
We don't have to worry
about that as much anymore.
And then there's always
going to be the support
for multiple ecosystems.
So there are going to be
new ecosystems in the future
that maybe we're
not thinking about.
But we want to make
sure that it's something
that we can easily apply
and move in the future,
where today we're building out
and customizing and integrating
a lot of capabilities because
of these monolithic systems
that we've had in the past, of
course, which weren't digital
ready, which weren't
designed for mobility.
But think about in
the future, there
could be different
types of devices.
So we showed devices around
wearables, for instance.
So we see more and more
interest in wearables for sure,
whether that's something
that you wear on your wrist
or nurses can wear
wearables around their neck.
Or we're working
with a cruise line
that wants to put wearables and
get rid of keys and car keys.
And so it becomes more and more
part of what people are using.
So it could be different
devices, different hardware
pieces that people are using.
So different types
of ecosystems.
And building customized
apps doesn't go away.
So as we mentioned, there's
a small percentage today
of off-the-shelf
app development.
It's only around
30% of apps today
are purely just off-the-shelf.
So the majority,
the vast majority
takes some customization.
The idea of the templatized
apps that Nisha talked about
was that there would
be 80% of the work done
with 20% customization,
it turns out
it's a lot more than
that needs to be done.
So there's always customization
So we're not ever going
to get away from that,
but you can see there's
different ways to customize.
And we don't look at everything
the same way anymore.
So now when we walk
into our clients,
we can figure out what
the requirements are first
and then decide, OK,
is it a native app?
Is it a web-based app?
Will it be a hybrid app?
Or some of these micro
apps and Instant Apps
are also options
that we can use.
And so we're not just
building a one size
fits all for our clients.
We have different
ways, depending
on the requirements
of their speed,
what their budget might
be, what the application
requirements are, their users,
the devices that they're using.
And so we're building
a whole different types
of different systems for them.
And we're doing
that intelligently.
Like I mentioned, almost
everything we're doing today,
especially out of our team
with digital transformation,
includes machine
learning, whether it's
voice-based capabilities
or moving away
from navigating the app
through the finger and all
through voice.
And we think that's
something that's
going to grow in the future.
And we've seen
great responsiveness
and great capabilities across
these devices for using this.
So we think something
like that is
going to become more of the
future of these different.
So we're thinking
about navigation.
We think about the
development, you
know, lots of changes that are
happening in these applications
today and that
will be continuing.
We have a mobile point of
view, or a point of view
in a white paper, that goes
into a lot more detail on this.
And if you want to give
me your business card,
I'm happy to send
you the link to that.
And you can get more
detailed information
both on the front end and
the back end development
to kind of walk away with this.
And then, of course, the
slides will be available.
And this will be available
on YouTube later today.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
We have a few minutes left
to take some questions.
Nisha will come back up.
Any questions out there?
If you do, please come up
and speak in the microphone,
because we will be recording
all this for posterity later.
NISHA SHARMA: Yeah, I
did just want to add--
I mean, hopefully you've seen
throughout this presentation
how we really truly are
moving to this next generation
of applications.
And it's because of all
the hardware changes,
the software changes
on the device side,
but also what's happening
in the back end and all
the new capabilities
that are available to us.
And you know, Phil
and I, we both work
on our Google partnership team.
And three years ago, more
than three years ago,
we started working
with the Android team.
And it was all about
how do we do more
with Android in the enterprise?
And one of the things we really
touched upon and talked about
was that Google really does
have that end-to-end technology
stack.
And that is their real
differentiation that they have.
And so whether it's the
devices, whether it's
Android or the
wearables or the glasses
or the connected
devices, whatever
that might be, to the backend
machine learning, the image
recognition, of
course, the cloud
infrastructure and everything
that's needed there to support
these applications, we really
do get a nice, seamless
and really exciting experience.
And we've got lots
of great examples
that we can tell
you about further.
All right, well, we're
here if you guys need us.
And thank you very much for
joining and for listening.
Thank you.
PHILLIP REDMAN: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]